[Musik]
und jetzt das heute schon mit heinz wolf
uns marietta slomka guten abend auch an
diesem wochenende gibt es wieder demos
und proteste quer durch die republik
aber nicht nur gegen korona maßnahmen
sondern auch von gegnern der gegner
sozusagen von menschen also die das
radikale auftreten von corona skeptikern
und im verweigerern zunehmend nervt in
minden in ostwestfalen etwa gingen aus
protest gegen querdenker rund
zweieinhalbtausend auf die straße und in
dresden wurde vor der frauenkirche
der bislang rund 1500 dresdner
todesfälle der pandemie gedacht doch
auch wenn die gesellschaftliche mehrheit
die eindämmung des virus nach wie vor
richtig findet in der gastronomie kommt
mit den neuen zweig plus regeln nicht
jeder so gut klar wie das lokal mit dem
annegret oster ihrem bericht beginnt
mainzer café wilma wunder wird seit
anfang dezember das praktiziert was
jetzt bundesweit gelten soll 2g plus und
das funktioniert ganz ohne wunder-
ziemlich gut wir benutzen die checks um
den qr code auszuspähen schauen uns an
ist es die dritte impfung oder ist erst
die zweite gleichen das mit dem
personalausweis ab und dann
gegebenenfalls noch den test nach holz
genau checken erfolgt dann über low carb
oder kroner waren das heißt verschiedene
schritte die der gast aber mittlerweile
kennt von überall sich hängt das ist gar
kein problem und finde es super dass es
überall so gut kontrolliert wird mit
personalausweis und fühlt man sich auf
jeden fall sicher
jetzt also soll es einigkeit und
bundeseinheitlich kite geben nach
monatelangem regel flickenteppich und
das sogar über parteigrenzen hinweg
es ist generell in der krise so dass wir
immer dann besonders erfolgreich sind
wenn alle staatlichen ebenen an einem
strang ziehen das macht ja den wert
dieser ministerpräsidenten konferenzen
aus
uneinigkeit weiterhin beim thema
impfpflicht einig ist man allein daran
war dass wir die zahl der geimpften in
deutschland signifikant
erhöhen müssen
wir sind uns einig darüber dass hier das
auch auf einem möglichst einheitlichen
gemeinsamen weg machen sollten doch die
gewünschte einigkeit ist schwer und beim
thema zweig plus schon wieder makulatur
neben sachsen anhalt steht auch bayern
aus dort hält man zweig plus in
gaststätten für nicht verhältnismäßig
noch wird geprüft ob die regelung kommt
die drohgebärden dagegen jedenfalls sind
schon da wenn wir davon ausgehen darf
sonst sind wir überzeugt dass zweig
ausreicht ist eine zusätzliche
verschärfung nicht verhältnismäßig ist
dann werden wir sicherlich einem
betroffenen betrieb finden und dort die
verhältnismäßigkeit auch gerichtlich
prüfen müssen omikron steht nicht mehr
vor sondern in der tür und deutschland
wappnet sich in saarbrücken sollen grüne
bändchen dafür sorgen dass so wenig
kundschaft wie möglich vergrault wird
einmal zweig plus überprüft danach
freies shoppen in den angeschlossenen
läden ein wenig hoffnung für die händler
und ein wenig wahlkampf mehr ist das
nicht wir sind in einer besonderen
situation eine neue herausforderung
durch omikron die hoch infektiös ist die
möglicherweise nicht so viel krank macht
aber viele menschen gleichzeitig und da
wäre es hilfreich man hätte in der
hinterhand eben auch noch maßnahmen um
schnell reagieren zu können deswegen bin
ich sicher es wird auch nochmal
nachgesteuert werden müssen und es
braucht weitere konferenzen insofern war
das sicherlich nicht der weisheit
letzter schluss auch ob die neue
eingeschränkte quarantäne regelung der
weisheit letzter schluss war ist
umstritten
die befreiung davon für frisch geimpfte
oder genesene kontaktpersonen für den
marburger bund medizinisch fragwürdig
denn wir wissen
also man geht ein risiko ein wenn man
sagt gemusterte müssen gar nicht mehr in
quarantäne
andere töne auf der seite der händler
hier sorgt man sich um eine
funktionierende infrastruktur
im bereich der logistikstrukturen
der wahl demonstrierten in mehreren
städten wieder tausende menschen gegen
die korona maßnahmen hier in magdeburg
die meisten ohne maske von einigkeit ist
man auch hier weiter entfernt
wer wissen möchte wie es in einer corona
diktatur zu geht und was ein echter
lockdown ist möge nach china schauen in
anbetracht der nikon variante und wenige
wochen vor beginn der olympischen
winterspiele ist man in peking so nervös
das ist peking seine zero kowitz
strategie mit brachialen mitteln
durchsetzt sowie das tatsächlich nur
eine diktatur kann und will mit einer
teils gerade zu bizarren maßlosigkeit
etwa wenn menschen sogar verboten wird
lebensmittel und medikamente zu kaufen
seit über zwei wochen ist die
metropolregion mit 13 millionen menschen
hermetisch abgeriegelt jian liegt in
zentralchina und ist berühmt für die
antike terrakotta armee christiane
hofmann berichtet
familie lohr berichtet in einem online
tagebuch vom lock down in china sie
erzählen von den ersten tagen als eine
noch zum einkaufen durfte von leeren
regalen täglichen corona test und davon
als plötzlich alles zugemacht wurde
morgen dürfen private autos nicht mehr
fahren wenn man erwischt wird muss man
500 yuan strafe zahlen und kommt zehn
tage in haft seine frau erzählt dass
eine tante gemüse bekommen hat aber auch
das andere lebensmittel brauchen ihre
größte sorge aber ist dass ihre
wohnanlage wegen corona fällen so wie
diese hier geräumt wird und sie in eine
quarantäne einrichtung kommen die oft
ohne heizung sind
der blick ins logbuch leben von familie
lohr zeigt wie die lage intern immer
angespannter wird nach mehr als zwei
wochen lockdown werden in den sozialen
netzwerken die proteste laute und die
auswüchse diese strikten vorgehens mehr
und mehr sichtbar weil sie essen
einkaufen wollen wird ein mann
geschlagen ein anderer muss sich dafür
entschuldigen
einen aufschrei gab es weil eine
hochschwangere frau mit beschwerden
nicht ins krankenhaus gelassen wurde ihr
corona test war abgelaufen nach mehreren
stunden warten vor der tür war der
embryo tod zumindest das hatte
konsequenzen einige verantwortliche
wurden entlassen
ich entschuldige mich zutiefst für den
schlechten zugang zu medizinischer
behandlung dieser schwangeren und andere
besondere patientengruppen
eine tiefe verbeugung die die
widersprüchlichkeit der 0 kowitz
strategie zeigt die panik vor einer
großen infektionswelle im land führt zu
eilig aus dem boden gestampften
quarantäne lagern und schärfsten
kontrollmaßnahmen ohne rücksicht auf den
einzelnen präsident erwartet corona
freie winterspiele und jeder weiß wer
einen fehler macht haftet persönlich
dafür das leben zu nehmen das land china
versucht seine 0 kowitz strategie über
die olympischen spiele zu retten deshalb
müssen sich auch die olympia teilnehmer
auf strenge kontrollen einstellen in
drei olympischen zonen werden sie von
der chinesischen bevölkerung abgeschirmt
das staatsfernsehen sendet derweil
unbeschwertes von den olympischen
vorbereitungen heute von den proben für
die eröffnungsfeier das bild des china
der welt von den winterspielen zeigt
muss perfekt sein präsident will es so
aus jetzt erst mal die nachrichten von
hans wolff
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht hat
bei ihrer ersten auslandsreise im neuen
jahr jordanien besucht auf einem
luftwaffenstützpunkt informierte sie
sich über die deutsche beteiligung beim
internationalen einsatz gegen die terror
miliz wie es in der hauptstadt amman
traf lambrecht jordaniens könig abdullah
den zweiten und sprach mit ihm über die
vertiefung der zusammenarbeit zwischen
deutschland und jordanien das land sei
ein wesentlicher sicherheitsanker in der
region so das verteidigungsministerium
die vereinten nationen starten einen
vermittlungsprozess im sudan wie der
un-sonderbeauftragte perthes mitteilte
ziele dieser prozess darauf einen weg
aus der politischen krise hin zu frieden
und demokratie zu unterstützen im sudan
kam es seit dem jüngsten putsch des
militärs im oktober vergangenen jahres
zu protesten bei denen dutzende menschen
getötet wurden
der höchste vulkan auf den galapagos
inseln ist jetzt nach mehr als sechs
jahren wieder ausgebrochen am rand des
rund 1700 meter hohen vulkans auf der
größtenteils unbewohnten hauptinsel
isabela flossen flossen lavaströme hinab
die inselgruppe liegt im pazifik mit
ihren seltenen tier und pflanzenarten
etwa der gründen riesenschildkröte
gehört sie zum unesco weltnaturerbe
bei den unruhen in kasachstan sind noch
viele fragen offen etwa warum die
proteste die im westen des landes
durchaus friedlich begann in der größten
stadt almaty dann so schnell in rohe
gewalt umschlugen steckt ein interner
machtkampf dahinter zwischen dem
aktuellen und dem früheren präsidenten
gab es womöglich agitatoren dagegen die
einschätzung politischer beobachter
durchaus auseinander
fest steht dass der kasachische
präsident das land mit seinem hilferuf
wieder näher an russland herangeführt
hat fest steht auch dass die breite
bevölkerung gute gründe hat gegen ihre
regierung aufzubegehren
axel sturm mit aktuellen eindrücken aus
kanada
noch hat die bäckereien amati genug brot
für alle sie stehen schlange für das
nötigste auch für benzin und flüssiggas
für die autos und für bargeld wer zum
zug kommen will braucht geduld wegen der
unsicheren lage kommen warenlieferungen
nur unregelmäßig an
die anderen supermärkte da unten etwas
weiter weg sind alle geschlossen aber
die leute müssen doch essen
die lage bleibt unübersichtlich diese
bilder sollen auch aus almaty stammen
nach wie vor spricht präsident lokale
von attacken gut ausgebildete
terroristen auf twitter postet er unter
anderem keine gespräche mit terroristen
wir müssen sie töten
an vielen orten checkpoints ein
militärbündnis aus armenien belarus
tadschikistan und vor allem russland hat
soldaten geschickt friedenstruppen
nennen sie sich zum ersten mal entsenden
alle mitgliedsstaaten des bündnisses
männer in einen heißen tanz einsatz
besonders in moskau mit man die lage
sehr ernst
erstens geht es um sicherheit man darf
nicht vergessen kasachstan ist ein
nachbarland mit 7500 kilometern
unbewachter grenze sich den
zusammenbruch eines landes vorzustellen
mit dem es keine grenze gibt das ist
weder einfach noch angenehm für moskauer
school toccata von putin haben viel
telefoniert und für putin sind die
ereignisse in kasachstan zentral nicht
nur aus sicherheitspolitischen gründen
auch weil er befürchten dürfte das in
den köpfen der menschen dort passiert
was in der ukraine passiert ist dass
moskau an einfluss verliert
in russlands interesse ist es die
verbindung zu kasachstan enger zu
gestalten
bislang hat das land eine sehr
balancierte außenpolitik betrieben
natürlich ist das land ein verbündeter
russlands aber es war auch nie im
konflikt mit dem westen
und so dürfte im aktuellen chaos putin
auch total apps innenpolitisches
großreinemachen unterstützen heute heißt
es karim asimov sei festgenommen worden
der ex-geheimdienstchef
tatvorwurf landesverrat
die regierung hatte totale schon vorher
kassiert und auch nursultan nasarbajew
die graue eminenz musste den vorsitz im
sicherheitsrat aufgeben
kasachstan bricht auf in eine neue
zukunft es ist eine ungewisse inacker am
kaspischen meer jedenfalls machen sie
klar schiff wollen dass es weitergeht
wie darüber gibt es wohl
unterschiedliche meinungen
ein weiterer wichtiger schritt zur
inbetriebnahme des neuen
weltraumteleskops james webb ist
geschafft wie die nasa mitteilte wurde
der über sechs meter große hauptspiegel
des teleskops vollständig ausgefahren
vor wenigen tagen bei der sonnenschutz
aufgespannt worden dann folgten die
spiegelsysteme das teleskop war vor rund
zwei wochen ins all gebracht worden und
soll die frühzeit des universums
erkunden
und jetzt die lottozahlen dieses
samstags sie lauten wie immer ohne
gewähr
2 17 19 30 32 38 superzahl 9 und weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und zdf text auf seite 55 6 die
wetteraussichten für morgen im westen
etwas sonne sonst meist stark bewölkt
mit teils länger anhaltenden regen oder
schnee fallen starker im bergland
stürmische wind aus meist westlichen
richtungen ein bis sieben grad die
weiteren aussichten am montag noch etwas
schnee sonst in den nächsten tagen
ruhiges wetter mit einer mischung aus
sonne wolken und nebel minus 4 grad im
südosten bis plus sechs grad im
nordwesten
das aktuelle sportstudio dann gegen 0.25
die nächste heute express sehen
[Musik]